CBS News contributor Nicholas Thompson
is editor-in-chief of Wired he
interviewed Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg
last month about Facebook's privacy
problems Nick good morning or good all
right an apology contrition promising
change but today in this hearing
what are these senators want in terms of
new regulatory efforts well if they
actually push for new regulatory efforts
the simple thing to do would be to
regulate advertisements on Facebook the
next step would be to have privacy
requirements you could also imagine
conversations about new regulations on
data breaches and then you can imagine a
much sort of larger discussion about how
social media platforms should be
regulated in general that would be great
if that happens it would be really good
for the country and really good for the
tech industry we'll see how much of that
there is and how much of sort of
back-and-forth fighting apologies right
just Zuckerberg is a punching bag up
there today is he fighting for his job
in a sense I mean he's he's fighting for
Facebook's popularity he's fighting for
the engineers who are demoralized he's
fighting for the sense that Facebook is
a force for good in this country which
is really important to him but he
totally controls that company and the
board loves them they're not going to
get this is the goal for him to show
that the barn door has been closed or
show that he has put systems in place to
recognize when the next door is open the
next problem yeah so the barn door
through which the cameras analytical
horses got out he closed that after they
got out but it was closed a long time
ago there about a hundred other barn
doors he's closed maybe 70 of them yeah
and they're negotiating on the other
thirty so yes exactly he's gonna be
talking about what they have done to
secure data over the last couple weeks
which is a lot what they're doing to
help you get control over your data
which is a lot what they can do in the
future because remember the core problem
is that Facebook's business model is to
learn as much about you as it can and to
sell targeted ads that requires them
getting data right so that's complicated
so their core models it tension with
putting some of these new constraints on
and every time you put a constraint on
you make the platform less useful in
certain ways for users as well so they
don't want to lock down privacy in every
way here's a really interesting thing
yesterday Facebook announced they're
going to let outside experts
analyze Facebook data to see if there's
been election manipulation what that
means they're giving data to people
right in order to do all this stuff you
need to share the data it's really hard
what's the thing that scares him the
most that they're gonna suggest from
Congress that he wants to avoid at all
costs in terms of future regulations in
German regulation so the German hate
speech regulation which says if somebody
Flags something is hate speech on your
platform you have 24 hours to get rid of
it which is really really hard for them
and actually if that comes up he'll say
it's counterproductive because it means
that they just sort of wipe everything
away and it allows that easy to get
politicized how closely will other tech
companies and their leaders be following
the hearings today we know YouTube has
been accused of improperly using
children's information right yeah so
YouTube be watching very carefully
Twitter will be watching very carefully
whatever regulations come for Facebook
will come for all the platforms and
they're also watching just cuz it's a
big moment for Silicon Valley right
everyone used to always love everything
about Silicon Valley now Silicon Valley
gets pummeled for everything so they'll
be watching this as a sign of where's
their popularity right now always good
to have you near that glad to be here
Thanks CBS News will bring you live
coverage of Mark Zuckerberg Capitol Hill
testimony find it on our streaming
network cbsn available at CBS news.com
and our CBS news radio stations starting
at 2:15 Eastern 1:15 Central